herzlich willkommen zum großen Cars 2
special auf klick-zoom mit
sensationellen Gästen und an der
sensationellen Aktion der Versteigerung
dieses Lightning McQueen zugunsten der
Aktion ein Herz für Kinder auf bild.de
zum Beispiel mit den Unterschriften von
Rick cavanian und John Leicester dem
Regisseur so und unser Gast erster Gast
ist Rick cavanian er spricht den kleinen
Fiat 500 aber ich unterhalte mich unter
anderem zum Beispiel über seine Hemden
mit ihm und ähm wir denn überhaupt zu
diesem Job gekommen ist also dran
bleiben
eine Sekunde Moment wo sind mein Stuhl
ich hätte schwören können dass es sich
dabei
hier
Wahnsinn
IG in dem Mikro Hammer hallo alles klar
also liebe Leute ich weiß auf der
falschen Seite jetzt muss ich mal raus
eine Sekunde wir machen uns wieder
gleich total spontan er kommt gleich
noch mal
ich tue noch mal Gedanken versuchen
hey hey Stuhl entschuldige bitte
so ja
der ist schön warm jetzt ja
Christoph
König ich bin cool
okay wie ist die Lage gut und bei dir
Sensation
sitzen ja das bist du ne das bin ich im
kleinen und auf vier Rädern mit
Kopfhörer und fühlte sich so in deiner
Mitte in diesem Auto oder ich fühle mich
ich fahre den Wagen auch mittig ja das
ist lecker
dann wird gefahren italienisch
vorbereitet natürlich bin ich
vorbereitet
aber ich weiß nicht ob du happy bist
damit ich habe so 69-seitiges besser
Heft bekommen da stand nicht drin ob du
happy bist oder nicht das ist eine
Unverschämtheit
anfügen da gehört auch hin ja ja wissen
das eigentlich entstanden
du ehrlich gesagt ich weiß es gar nicht
Disney war so freundlich und dachte sich
Mensch wer könnte tun im Deutschen
sprechen und ist schon eine Ehre also
ich bin ein großer Fan von Monk auch ja
und ich finde er ist toll gemacht und
ich mir macht es Spaß also ich habe
einfach Freude dran und wenn da so ein
erster Anruf kommt und wahrscheinlich
ist Management ruft an andere Sachen von
Disney hättest du Lust springt man dann
sofort hoch und sagt ja das würde ich
machen oder ich habe noch das
bei dir letzte ist nein es ist nein ich
freue mich halt weil ich ich mag das
halt ja und bei Disney ist halt schon
immer so so eine gewisse Qualität sehr
schön Beständigkeit und auch
Innovationsfreude und macht schon Spaß
ist eine Ehre ja okay und ähm macht das
mehr Spaß als vor der Kamera stehen
also ich kann das schwer vergleichen ich
kann es wirklich schwer vergleichen was
halt hier schön ist man hat ein festes
Dach und geregelte Mahlzeiten
Dreh nicht immer aber was wirklich
ähnlich ist also es ist es verlangt
schon dieselbe Körperlichkeit also ich
muss wenn ich gerade Luigi spricht er
ist ja doch sehr aufbrausend emotional
der spielt sich dann schon mal so eine
Stange T-Shirts durch okay und beim
Drehen gibt es auch so egal ob jetzt ein
zeckenkostüm oder Frau Klamotten anhast
das ist auch schweißtreibend also es ist
am Abend weiß ich von meistens was ich
dann davor getan habe aber das schöne
ist ja wahrscheinlich du kannst den
Joggen Anzug machen oder was was trägst
du das wird mir interessieren weil vor
der Kamera Kostüm geschminkt Dings und
normal also T-Shirt Jeans und
Jogginganzug darüber
so ist das deine Lieblingsfarbe oder
deine das ist die Lieblingsfarbe meiner
Frau
stehen aber ich habe gehört also
mittlerweile gab es schon zwei drei
Komplimente von Menschen die mich völlig
spontan angesprochen hat
dass dir deine Frau bestimmt gekauft hat
und woher wisst ihr das Nein gerne
am liebsten kariert und ich weiß nicht
ob du es weißt schon trägt ja immer
dieser weinenden ja das habe ich gehört
von dir gerade also immer was ich gehört
habe immer passend zur Gelegenheit wie
ist das bei dir hast du bestimmte Farben
zu bestimmten Gelegenheit das ist jetzt
dein Interview Hemd das ist mein
Interview passende Hände zulegen
eigentlich glaube ich weniger aber
vielleicht ich finde das eine gute Idee
man weiß sofort was los ist genau Kaffee
Kaffee oder vielleicht nach Laune
ich bin ja ständig gut gelaunt deshalb
ätzend ist das auch bei dir so nein es
geht ich habe schon auch traurige
Gemeinde okay es war nicht wirklich
traurig und hast du denn zum Ausgleich
der guten Laune mir wird es nach gesagt
ich werde zu allen kollegisch ehrlich ja
ja was bist du für Sternzeichen Löwe ja
er ist cholerisch
ich bin cholerisch
du bist cool
aber das macht nichts ich finde es aber
du bist laut sympathische Leute die sind
laut unsympathisch dann begrenzwertig
okay das stimmt natürlich wie ist das
bei dir bist du laut oder bist du eher
leise was bist du also ich glaube privat
leise und sobald Geld eine Rolle spielt
lauter okay nein das wäre jetzt verlogen
ich bin doch keine nein nein ich ähm
funktioniert ohne Geld
und ja du gehst ich meine du bist ein
Mensch der unglaublich viel mit Stimme
umgeht sich da warte ich mit
auseinandersetzt
wie redest du am liebsten privat
eigentlich so wie also wenn jetzt die
Kamera nicht liefe würde ich
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen leiser reden
aber im Grunde ich ich ich ich mag das
gepflegte zivilisierte domestizierte
Gespräch mit einem möglichst friedlichen
Ausgang okay da lege ich auch meistens
drauf an ähm wenn du oder Nein anders
gefragt als du dein Talent entdeckt hast
oder wie nennt man so Talent das hat
wirklich lange gedauert ich habe mit im
zarten Alter von 19 Jahren mit Bully
Herbig bei mir angefangen und da war mir
nicht klar was ich sage ich mal
eventuell könnte oder wie wichtig die
Sprache und Stimme ist und das hat sich
nach und nach entwickelt also ich habe
eigentlich erst im Alter von 26 gemerkt
okay also wirklich sexy ja ja deshalb
wirklich lang gedauert und jetzt habe
ich das Glück dass ich die letzten paar
Jahre doch davon leben ja überleben darf
und jetzt langsam würde ich auch sagen
okay ich weiß einigermaßen was ich kann
und was ich nicht kann ist quasi sowieso
ein Kapital ich glaube schon
es gibt ja so Sprecher die so
unglaubliche Stimmen haben natürlich
auch das ist wirklich wie so ein Kapital
ja super dann danke ich dir vielmals die
Kollegen die macht immer so ich glaube
das heißt
rasieren okay aber ich hatte auch
irgendwas mit Ende zu tun
vielen vielen Dank hat mir große Freude
bereitet und ein toller Film übrigens
auch gut